we're about to see behind the scenes of
the fountains of bellagio what makes all
of this work
right here we have two of the shooters
it says people are always wondering
what's in the lake well this right here
is
a super shooter this actually shoots the
water over 220 feet this right here is
the mini shooter we have 780 of these
but then we also have 16 of the extremes
which is basically if you
sandwich three of these together that
would make an extreme shooter you can
actually almost
dive inside one raise the nozzle shields
and that's when you know the show's
about to start
when you see the nozzle shield start to
protrude and rise out of the water you
know the magic's about to start
i want to give all of you a behind the
scenes look at the fountains of bellagio
starting off with this right here this
is the norsemen these are the ladies
that actually do all the work in the
lake for the most part these are the
original devices that were here
over 20 years ago this is what causes
all the waters to move back and forth
and basically dance and choreograph the
music the water is tested on a daily
basis to make sure that the water is
healthy for us to be able to dive in and
also since we throw it up in the air we
want to make sure that it's also healthy
for the public everyone that works here
at the front future has to be speed
assertive
we don't dive like normal divers normal
divers will have what they call the bc
it helps them stay afloat it also helps
them to not touch the bottom of the
surface
here
we want to sink like a water this is my
personal weight though
[Music]
the water at this time is
56.6 degrees
[Music]
we really can't do what we can what we
do out here without the assistance and
the help of chill control if we need a
device to be raised they're the ones who
do that for us it's very complicated
give a command to just one device
considering we have over 15 000 of them
out here may we please fire off super
please raise one of the horsemen up to
maintenance position
so where's the best place to see
the show and you're trying to capture
the whole show as a whole well one great
place
is actually up there
by the marquis there's a walkway from up
there you can get to see the whole show
another great place
is at the very very end at the north end
of our walkway once again you can see
the whole show you can actually see the
lights on the structure as they're going
across it's pretty neat i've been
watching this show now for over 20 years
it never gets old
[Music]